hello everybody good morning and welcome
to Sky News breakfast
we start with some breaking news this
morning State media in Iran has claimed
that British Iranian National alireza
akbari has been executed the former
senior defense official had been accused
of working for British intelligence and
was sentenced to death last week
well let's bring in our Middle East
correspondents Alistar bunkel who's on
the phone for us now Alistair really
worrying reports from Iran's State media
so what can you tell us
yeah and and I think the first thing to
say is that the reporting is coming from
what's known as the mizzen news agency
now this news agency has close links to
the Iranian Judiciary uh and so for that
reason I think we can take these reports
it's been incredible and accurate I'm
afraid and that is that Ali razakhbari
has been executed uh by the Iranian
regime today as they had threatened to
do now just to recap over who he was and
his story he was once the former deputy
defense minister in Iran so he held a
very failure position within uh the
Iranian government Iranian security set
up but the Iranians charged him
and accuse them spying for Britain and
said that he received hundreds of
thousands of pounds uh to give
information and intelligence to Britain
he is uh I should say a dual National a
dual British Iranian National so he has
familiar links to Britain although Iran
doesn't recognize dual nationality which
made it very hard for uh the British
government to get into kind of Consular
access to him whilst he was being held
in prison the foreign secretary James
cleverley earlier this week as the
reports of his pen the execution became
uh clearer and closer did describe this
as politically motivated uh the U.S
state Department said that they would be
watching Iran's actions on this very
closely indeed and there was
um a visit made by his family to his
prison on Wednesday they were they were
called to the prison where they found
him in solitary confinement they said uh
to pay what was described as a final
visit to him on Wednesday as well he
also recorded the voice note that was
costs on BBC Persian
and he said that he confessed to the
alleged crimes against him under torture
so he said it was because he was being
tortured that he made false confessions
but he always protested his innocence he
always said that he was not a spy for
Britain and despite the British attempts
to persuade the Iranians not to go ahead
with this despite American pressure as
well the Iranian regime as they have
done with others linked to the ongoing
protests they have sentenced him to
death and executed alireza akbari this
morning
Ali thanks very much indeed for that
now England is taking the next step in
ending the scourge of single-use plastic
litter after a ban on plastic stirrers
straws and cotton buds in 2020 this year
we'll see an end to plastic plates and
Cutlery to enforce the ban the
government says it's prepared to make
rule breaches a criminal offense well
estimates suggest that we use 2.7
billion pieces of single-use Cutlery in
England every year as well as 721
million single-use plates but only 10
percent of this single-use plastic ends
up being recycled Becky Cottrell reports
we're so used to seeing these in
takeaway shops polystyrene containers
have become key to grabbing food or
drinks on the go useful and cheap but an
environmental hazard so many single-use
Plastics will be banned in England from
October businesses will have to find
biodegradable Alternatives like wooden
Cutlery or paper cups the manager at
this Cafe in East London is worried
about the cost at a time when they're
already struggling absolutely every
piece of stock everything you see every
item of food has risen in price within
the last one year so you know this
little thing it may seem like you know
something small but it's not
the government says the public is
overwhelmingly in favor of the ban but
it's a big shift for the hospitality
sector in particular coming up in Autumn
we've worked very very closely with
business and industry because we
obviously realize there's an impact on
them and this gives them time to get to
use up stop that they've already got
because they didn't want to just have to
ditch it that doesn't really make sense
either the change follows similar moves
in Scotland and Wales packaging like
this used for Supermarket meals will not
be banned but conservation Charities
want the government to go further faster
we really need to see that the plastic
pollution tap turned off what we're
seeing at the moment now is essentially
policies that are bailing out the bath
water and and we need to see those
policies implemented in a in a strategic
coordinated approach across all of the
Nations within the UK the cost to the
environment currently is clear plastic
washing up on beaches or poisoning
Marine Wild life but now businesses and
perhaps customers will face the cost of
making our waste less toxic Becky
Cottrell Sky News
in Ukraine the battle for solidar is
continuing Russia claims to have taken
the small salt mining town in the east
of the country but those reports are
denied by Kiev it will be a rare and
delayed victory for President Putin's
military though much of the fighting has
been carried out by mercenaries in the
Wagner Group Well solidar is still being
pounded by artillery day and night and
Sky News has seen Ukrainian forces
digging trenches there from there our
International correspondent Alex Rossi
reports
foreign
the air crackles with the sound of
gunfire
Ukrainian and Russian troops are
engaging At Close Quarters
the Kremlin claims to have captured the
salt mining town of solidar but holding
it may be another matter
units wait on standby to Medevac troops
armored vehicles rushing along broken
roads attending to the injured
as we move closer to the entrance of the
town we found deserted houses and
abandoned animals
both sides have taken serious casualties
under the Relentless barrages of
artillery
very few people have remained in this
area and as we pass destroyed homes the
bombs started falling once again
well there's a lot of
fighting still going on here
we've just
had the sound of a shell Screech
overhead
that's not clear exactly what's going on
inside solidar but it seems that the
ukrainians have been pushed out
and are very much on the outskirts at
the moment but the big concern is for
civilians who are still trapped inside
this terrifying War has destroyed
communities forcing millions of people
from their homes
it's hard to see how they will return to
these places
further back from the front line
soldiers wait for their orders solidar
may have fallen but they say Russia has
lost a large number of men for not much
gain
Ed
[Music]
um
foreign
this will be the first victory over
Ukrainian forces by Russia after months
of military setbacks
but as Ukraine fortifies its positions
it's unlikely to make much difference to
the outcome of this conflict
and in the fields of dead sunflowers new
trenches are being dug
this war of attrition is brutal and is
seemingly without ends Alex Rossi Sky
News on the outskirts of solidar
hormone replacement therapy HRT has
helped millions of women enjoy better
healthier lives well now researchers
claim that it could help prevent
Alzheimer's disease in some women well
our correspondent shiman Freeman Powell
is here with me to tell me a little bit
more about this this sounds promising so
what do researchers saying it is really
promising especially given the fact that
around two-thirds of Alzheimer's
patients currently in the UK are women
so dementia is something that massively
impacts women in the UK and dementia and
menopause could potentially be linked as
well because researchers looking at this
study found that the high prevalence of
Dementia in women could potentially be
linked to symptoms caused by the
menopause as well and it all links back
to this Gene called the apoe4 gene it's
the strongest risk factor Gene for
Alzheimer's and around a quarter of
women in the UK are thought to be
carriers so what these researchers from
the University of East angular and
University of Edinburgh be looking at is
this hormone replacement therapy which
is used for the menopause it's helped
women it helps women with symptoms of
the menopause and it found that those
that had this Gene that I referenced
those with this Gene had better brain
function when taking this hormone and
the researchers found that it was better
for women that had four women if they
took this hormone replacement therapy
early on in that perimenopause phase so
the researchers found that this HRT was
actually associated with better memory
with better cognitive functions and
larger brain volumes later in life with
women with this Gene so it is very
promising however researchers are
pointing out that it's not definitive it
can't there's no direct link to say that
it will definitely help women with
dementia but it is promising considering
that around 900 000 people in the UK
currently have dementia this is this
figure is expected to rise and over
coming years as well and of course it
has a huge knock-on effect to how our
Health and Social care sector as well so
this is promising but not definitive
just yet more research needed
interesting stuff though Siobhan thanks
very much indeed
now demonstrations against a coal mine
in a condemned German Village are
expected to Peak this weekend Riot
police have already moved in to clear
protesters in luzarad who are preventing
it from being demolished there are plans
to remove the town to make way for an
expanding coal mine well let's get some
reaction to this I'm joined Now by
Louisa neubauer who's one of the leading
activists who are currently protesting
Louise know about very good morning to
you thanks so much for talking to us
explain to us why you and the other
activists there are so concerned about
the expansion of this mine
yeah I mean I guess it's important to
understand here we're speaking of the
largest single source of CO2 in the
whole of Europe that was what this cool
area and the Ryan land in Germany is so
closing this down as soon as anyhow
possible it's not just a German
responsibility but it concerns people
across the world because they are
affected by those emissions and what
we're seeing now is that the German
government made a deal with the coal
company behind this and that allows that
co-company to extract far more code than
we should be able to burn to stay in
line with our promises made with the
Paris agreement hence we're protesting
yeah and on the subject of that deal
they did a deal that allows it to expand
this it's coal mine but they then in
return have pledged to end coal use by
2030 rather than 2038 some might say
it's a short-term hit now at a time of
an energy crisis but longer term that's
good news
yeah maybe it's one of those deals that
sounds too good to be true and that is
in fact a green washing deal because the
end day 2030 so this cool exit date that
was being said doesn't mean much if the
amount of code that is being burned
until then is just way too big so what
we need to do is we need to limit the
amount of coal that is being burned
until 2023 or 2030 and that's what we're
really fighting for here and then I
guess it's really important also to
acknowledge that the coal under the
village is not needed to secure
Germany's energy Supply so what is being
made up here is this crisis narrative
where the government comes up to tackle
the prices with the coal effectively
just creates way more crises than we can
ever tackle okay well let's talk about
the crisis then because as you say the
German government say they feel they
have no choice they cite Russia's
invasion of Ukraine as saying that
that's prompted an energy security
crisis especially for countries like
Germany that have been relying on on
Russian gas they say they need this coal
or there's a risk they can't keep the
lights on and they risk rolling
blackouts yeah I think it's really not
responsible to throw around these
narratives when the reality is the coal
under the specific Village is not
accessible to the coal company within
the next two years that's for logistical
reasons because it's just very deep down
in the soil so telling people that this
would do anything to secure energy
Supply that's [ __ ] to be to be frank
here and then we also I'm just going to
cut in that apologies Louise and English
not your first language you're very
fluent but we can't say that this time
in the morning that's fine I'm just
going to apologize to any any viewers
that might be offended no anyway do
continue this is something you know
that's wrong and what we also know is
that the that the coal um that is around
the village so the coal accessible to
the coal company and you know there's
there's enough coal that can be burned
um without yeah distracting that very
Village so the numbers are quite clear
that the science is quite clear and what
we're seeing that the German government
is ignoring the science is ignoring the
voices of 700 scientists that just came
out this week saying this Village must
stay the coal shouldn't be touched
um under the ground there
um and yeah and so this is there's in
many ways very irresponsible and also
um yeah sending a signal around the
world that apparently as a government in
2023 you can ignore International
climate agreements you can ignore the
science and you could ignore your
responsibility to really um yeah take
climate action
so what kind of will that action look
like today how big do you expect the
protest to be and I understand Greta
thundberg is expecting to join you as
well yeah Greta is already around here
really which is wonderful we are seeing
an overwhelming amount like path of
society really coming up this very
moment thousands are planning their
Journey up to the Village just now so
we're expecting more than 10 000 people
to come at least it's wonderful to see
also farmers and churches and people
from really all generations that that
Unite Here and behind our common
struggle for climate justice so in a way
this is also a big moment for for
democracy for civil society that says we
are willing to stand up if a government
doesn't draw the line and says enough is
enough when it comes to destruction it
is up to us to do that okay well Louise
we appreciate your time this morning
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thanks for having me
now more than 200 flood warnings and
alerts are in place across the UK as
strong winds sweep rain across the
country worst hit are Western England
and Wales forecasters say next week
could bring snow even well Sky
meteorologist Joe Wheeler joins me now
from Lincolnshire so Joe what's behind
all of this cold weather heading our way
well of course we are seeing some very
changeable conditions and this all
started with that big snowstormer in the
states which basically uh invigorated
the jet stream which started pushing all
this very active weather toward us right
at the moment we've got low pressure
system after low pressure system stacked
up in the Atlantic and that's when you
changeable conditions but of course as
those go through occasionally we get
locked into a Northerly flow and that's
pretty much what's going to happen over
the next few days
um so that coal there actually follows
this rain today it kind of focus in from
the Northwest and then we'll see
temperatures drop in Sub-Zero
temperatures overnight and of course the
risk of some wintry hazards things like
snow and ice certainly some Coastal
wintry showers we'll see over the next
few days starting with this morning I
can say it's not yet 7 30 and I'm
already on my second umbrella the first
one just gave up the ghost as I walked
outside so it's pretty pretty blustery
sort of regretting the blow dry as well
um so yes part of the West have seen
over an inch of rain overnight and these
very strong winds guessing at times up
to around 60 miles per hour now there's
nothing like that here but of course
this is quite blustery so this rain is
going to push its way through then as
things dry up from the West we'll see
showers following on and it's as those
showers come in that we start to see
temperatures dropping and as such I mean
we've got a number of warnings out first
of all for Wind and Rain uh for parts of
the West and then from tomorrow night
1800 through to Thursday the 19th of
January we've got this level two cold
weather alert and this is where around a
60 of people are going to trigger that
threshold that says we're going to see a
prolonged period of very cold weather so
really we're swapping these they're
fairly mild conditions and it is mild at
the moment uh if there's rain is
bringing in temperatures of around 12 to
13 degrees Celsius but then those
temperatures drop later in the day and
that cold weather is going to be with us
for the next few days
so I really hope that you're able to go
inside now it does look wet and windy
and uh thank you so much for enduring
that weather to to fill us in we just
had to look at the pictures to get a
sense of what it's like thanks very much
indeed hello very good morning you're
watching Sky News breakfast our top
stories here this morning Iran's State
media say The British Iranian man
alireza akbari has been executed after
being sentenced on charges of spying for
Britain
single-use plastic boxes plates and
Cutlery will be banned in England from
October as the government tries to
tackle their devastating impact on the
environment
[Music]
Temptations rise as ambulance drivers
say they're appalled and betrayed by
Minister's attempts to remove their
right to strike
State media in Iran has claimed that
British Iranian National alireza akbari
has been executed the former senior
defense official had been accused of
working for British intelligence and was
sentenced to death last week well in the
last few minutes the Prime Minister has
reacted to this news he's tweeted saying
I'm appalled by the execution of British
Iranian citizen Ali Reza akbari in Iran
this was a callous and cowardly act
carried out by a barbaric regime with no
respect for the human rights of their
own people my thoughts are with Ali
Reza's friends and family
well James cleverley the foreign
secretary has said Iran has executed a
foreign a British national this barbaric
act deserves condemnation in the
strongest possible terms this will not
stand unchallenged my thoughts are with
Ali Reza agbari's family
so reaction there from the British
government to this news well let's get
more reaction now joining me now is
Adnan tabatabai chief executive and Iran
analyst of the Middle East Think Tank
capro a very good morning to you
um first of all your reaction to Iran
State media's announcement today
well uh I think it has there has been
reports and there have also been claims
made in the past days that that
execution has already taken place so
there was a lot of question around this
case
um now it's really about what what are
the messages that are sent what are the
signals that are intended to be sent
both internally and externally uh by the
Iranian state so this is what currently
all questions are about
well yes and I'll come to that in just a
moment but first of all and obviously
um he maintained his instance throughout
he actually sent a voice note to BBC
Persian service this week where he says
he was tortured into a false a
confession
maintained his innocence throughout
everything as I say but what kind of
trial would he have had
look it's it's um it's it's like many
many cases there is it would be naive to
assume that no Iranian official is going
to be contacted or infiltrated or
however we want to call it by Foreign
agencies but the problem obviously also
is that the Judiciary System in Iran is
in no shape or form credible
particularly to the outside world so
it's difficult to really assess
um how much of it is true how much of it
was indeed forced confessions and of
course we have to assume that when he
says he was put under under drugs or he
was tortured to to confess to things
that there is something to it so again
this is this is another of I have to say
is zillion cases where a lot of
examination is needed to really find out
what exactly has happened and what is
really at stake
well yes and you say that Iran wants to
send out a message expand on that a
little what what do you mean look we
obviously have a time with with a lot of
internal turmoil
um we have seen executions of uh people
that were involved in the street
protests That was supposed to send the
message of deterrence for young people
to no longer come out onto the streets
to show that the state will punish them
with the harsh as possible in the
harshest possible ways and the case of
alireza akbari which is not a new one
apparently this the the legal procedures
have been happening in the past years is
now also sending a message to in fact
State actors to political figures that
if you have done anything wrong or if
you have been contacted and working with
foreign agencies this is the Fate that
you will have to
um to face so this is also a deterrence
message to to state actors in fact and
to the to the International Community if
you will or to Britain and other
countries this is what will happen if
you work with some of our some of the
members of of the state Elite and I
think this intentionally or
unintentionally are the messages that
are sent well yes and a huge reaction
from the British government we saw the
Prime Minister condemning at this act
and James cleverley the foreign
secretary as well saying Iran has
executed a British national at the
barbaric act deserves condemnation in
the strongest possible terms and he goes
on to say this will not stand
unchallenged what do you expect next
from the British government and the
International Community in response to
this
yeah I mean in fact
um cynically this is part of the play
and this is part of what the Iranian
state is expecting to to see and to read
um by confirming that he's a British
citizen the whole issue about an Iranian
official being a dual National working
for a foreign agency and then the
government speaking out what they
obviously have to do and condemn this
execution is part of the script I assume
that other European countries
particularly the E3 will of course chime
in and um and condemn the the execution
so we really have unfortunately a very
cynical cycle of messages going back and
forth and unfortunately we have to
assume that more cases like this may be
not necessarily political officials but
other others that were involved in the
turmoil of the past weeks and months uh
will unfortunately follow
are very interested to get your take on
things thanks very much indeed for your
for your response thank you thanks for
having me bye
and it may feel like a rare strike for a
couple of days but the bitter talks
across Industries continue one ambulance
Workers Union has written to the Prime
Minister accusing Ministers of singling
them out into deliberate attacks
meanwhile some hope in Scotland where
healthcare workers have suspended
strikes in return to returning to the
negotiating table our political
correspondent Rob Powell joins me now so
Rob some progress perhaps north of the
Border but what about the the tone of
the dialogue further south yeah I think
in some places in the negotiations with
the Westminster government it seems to
be going into reverse I think evidence
of that overnight very strongly worded
letter from the GMB Union that
represents ambulance workers that went
on strike on Wednesday in England and
Wales they're very unhappy about
suggestions from ministers uh that Union
officials were essentially slow to
guarantee that certain Staffing and
services would be put in place to ensure
that the most urgent ambulance call outs
actually got a prompt response and
they're unhappy that that accusation is
being essentially used as part of the
reason to bring in new laws to guarantee
minimum service levels essentially to
force some people to work and to force a
certain level of service to be provided
um even on strike days Steve Rice who's
the uh from the gmb's ambulance
committee has written a letter to Rishi
sunak can read you part of it he says we
feel utterly betrayed by the way your
government has singled out ambulance
workers as part part of a crude attempt
to remove our right to strike you and
your ministers should be ashamed of the
way you have tried to paint us as
uncaring about safety standards nothing
could be further from the truth now
Downing Street says that it values
ambulance staff and NHS workers it's
pointing to the fact that it accepted
the pay recommendation for this
financial year and it said that new laws
were needed to protect the public and to
guarantee safety for the public on
strike days I think what you're starting
to see though is some of the tone in
which the government in Westminster has
conducted these negotiations combined
with the fact that they are putting
forward these new laws both of those
things seem to be souring the ongoing
discussions and potentially making a
deal harder to reach people will also
potentially notice that in Scotland
negotiations between the Scottish
government there and various trade
unions seem to be progressing a little
bit better strike action has been paused
while while those talks um continue so
that potential actually doesn't reflect
well on the Westminster government
either I think though even if there was
a change in tone you really have a
material problem in Westminster as well
whereby actually there are figures in
depart the Department of Health that
seem to be in a more deal making mode
now accepting that more money needs to
be put forward the issue is the treasury
is saying that any increased pay
settlement will have to come from
existing budgets so loads of
difficulties more strikes due next week
in the NHS and no deal seems at the
moment to be in sight
no indeed Rob thanks very much indeed
for that
now then let's check in on the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well after a wet start to the weekend
things will turn much colder on Sunday
with an increasing risk of snow and ice
Saturday morning will be wet and windy
across much of Britain with snow over
Northern Hills and Coastal Gales in the
South overnight rain will have eased
across Ireland the rain will be heavy at
times before clearing East into the
North Sea and could cause further
flooding issues for parts of Wales and
Western England sunshine and glossary
showers will feed in from the West on
strong and Gusty Westerly winds the
showers will turn heavy and persistent
across Northern Ireland with wind gusts
here widely up to 50 miles an hour and
high near the North Coast it stays windy
overnight with further blustery showers
and these will be wintry over High
ground and a more persistent rain band
will affect Northern Ireland parts of
Scotland and then later Northern England
it'll turn much colder on Sunday in
brisk Northerly winds with a mixture of
Sunny spells and increasingly wintry
Showers of hail sleet and snow
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Chinese breakfast coming
up we're going to take you through the
morning papers with the broadcaster and
journalist afia Hagen and writer and
academic Mo love it
[Music]
so time now to go through the morning
papers here with me to review them are
the broadcaster and journalist afia
Hagen and writer and academic Mo love it
so welcome back to both of you and we're
going to delve inside the papers for
this hour aren't we and mo you're going
to kick us off an article you spotted
inside this morning's Mirror newspaper
reflecting on yesterday's growth figures
the GDP figures that came out yesterday
morning
yeah so a little bit of good news I
think um looks like Britain's set to
avoid an economic downturn and figures
from the economy show that um it grew by
0.1 percent okay it's quite a small
amount but it did go in the right
direction and that was in the month of
November
um so um and it was all it was predicted
to uh decline by 0.2 so
um so so that seems like it's good news
and figures from the ftse 100 also uh
closed it record high
um in that month and it the paper and
several analysts are putting it down to
the fact that the World Cup gave a boost
to the economy particularly the food and
drink industry which was boosted by 2.2
and so generally good news it might mean
um sadly that there'll be pressure on
the bank of England to increase interest
rates which might not suit
um mortgage um owners like Marcel
um but generally it's quite good news
it's a short blip I think in it in a
kind of longer term uh picture which is
a little bit more gloomy so I think um
you know there's no need to rest on our
Laurels we really do need to kind of
look at how we increase productivity in
in the UK economy
um but certainly
um it's meant that we've avoided that
kind of technical definition of a
recession going into a fall or two
consecutive quarters a little bit of
good news well yeah that's right and all
eyes on on whether or not um inflation
will come down because that seems to be
one of the big uh problems doesn't it
um so we'll we'll keep an eye on that in
the meantime Affair you wanted to to
turn to a double page spread with some
pretty shocking pictures in the mirror
yes that's right so this is um an
investigation in the Daily Mirror by
their environment correspondent and this
is about
um so someone who lives in Essex who
goes on these hunting holidays
essentially to South Africa where he's
seen killing Lions as you can see here
at Deborah's bears and other parts of
the world for sport and he is defending
uh shooting these wild animals and
endangered species I might add for fun
saying that he's playing a role in the
environment and also protecting these
animals from poachers even though he's
probably doing the same thing that
poachers do you're killing the animals
but just kill them for a task for other
bits of the body he's killing them for
fun he's trying to defend this by saying
that he does it in a more humane way and
comparing it to the way that animals are
slaughtered in the United Kingdom and
but the problem here is is that he's
going on Hunting holidays for fun to to
kill endangered species like Lion
giraffes and rhinos in South Africa now
he has a license so he's saying that
British and American authorities don't
need to get involved but the point is is
that these are endangered species and
you're going to all other continent a
whole other country to shoot them for
fun and I don't think this would be
allowed if you were you know shooting
the neighbor's dogs or cats or something
like that so why is it allowed that he's
allowed to go to South Africa and kill
endangered species and post these
pictures on social media for fun yeah
and as you say a pretty robust defense
of what he's doing there in in the paper
as well and let's move on to a totally
different issue Mo you've picked out an
article here in the Daily Star which
um talks about what Gary lineker said
about MPS pay
yes it's just caught my eye a little bit
Gary lineker's saying that we need to
increase the MP's salary to get smarter
people to do a better job and that we
don't entice the best minds and I think
what he's doing is tapping into a kind
of general feeling of disillusionment
with our political class at the moment
and I just think he's going about it the
wrong way
um and he's certainly been highly
criticized for his comments on social
media I mean maybe for you know if you
earning 1.35 million salary MP salary
doesn't look that great but I think most
of us think 84k a year and rising to
100K if you're a minister isn't a bad
salary but I think part of the problem
is that we have this kind of
um kind of political class or career
politicians actually I'd like to see
more politicians who were kind of
motivated by a sense of Juicy and wanted
to emit the world or the country a
better place I think it's those career
politicians and the idea that it's a
um you know it's a way to earn a living
it is probably part of the a problem and
we talked about where streeting in the
you know in the first round of the
papers and there's a guy who's really
motivated to make some improvements and
you know it's not just on the labor
badge so I'm not being party political
yet but those are the politicians that
we want you know the people that have a
sense of Duty and want to make the
country a better place for their
constituents and I don't really think
salary is is the answer there I'm afraid
yeah interesting and where some people
say higher salary you might get the best
brains in the country more tempted into
politics rather than to other Industries
where they can pay more so it's quite an
interesting debate isn't it and let's
turn to uh Royal issues and it feels
like um ages since we talked about
um
Prince Harry but um there is a double
page spread here um still uh plenty of
coverage isn't there around in fact it's
on some of the front pages again this is
the Express's double page spread and I
feel tell us what it's telling us
well yes the Daily Express have
conducted a poll uh which they were
talked about the popularity of different
members of the royal family after the
release of Prince Harry's Memoir Despair
and it says here that popularity of King
Charles III is actually gone up 10 after
the release of the book but the queen
consort Camilla her popularity has gone
down by two percent now the Prince of
Wales and the prince and princess of
Wales have buried a bit better their
popularity has gone up for the Prince of
Wales at five percent and up for the
Princess of Wales nine percent but for
Prince Harry himself his popularity has
dipped by 39 and Megan the doctors of
Sussex her popularity has dipped by 35
so it seems that after the release of
there uh more people are finding
sympathy with the royal family with King
Charles especially rather than Prince
Harry himself now in town terms of
whether people think that Prince William
and Prince Harry will ever heal their
Rift
um most people thought that actually
they would at nine percent thought they
would heal their riff quite soon but 35
said yes but not in the short term now
the the conversation around Megan and
Harry being stripped of their titles has
been one that's been around for a long
time and this poor says that people
thought that 54 of them thought that yes
they should be stripped of their roles
at stripped of their titles excuse me of
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and 31 of
people thought that they should attend
the coronation and 44 of people thought
that they should stay away so lots of
varying opinions there coming out after
the release of spirit this week yeah I
mean everyone's had something to say
about it I haven't though there's been
so many opinions and I'd be really
curious to see what results you get to a
similar poll in America for example
whether or not they're viewed more
sympathetically there and the suggestion
is that that Harry and Megan are more
popular there anyway let's try and get
another story in MO this is inside the
guardian and this is the new AI chat bot
that is causing a few concerns
especially in schools and universities
yeah absolutely it's called chatbot chat
GPT and it's an app that can create
essays and stories and even kind of help
you write your job a job application it
comes out Elon Musk Elon musk's open AI
research laboratory and basically what
you do the EI is fed lots and lots of
words and then it comes out with
sentences based on probability of usage
a bit like like predictive texting on
your phone and but the concern within
universities is that students will use
it to write their essays not learn the
skill of writing essays and so one
University is even scrapped essay
writing as a method of a assessment in
grading students and I think they're
jumping they've gone a little bit
quickly there I mean you know good essay
the arts for good essay is um in in
structure and creativity and I'm not
sure AI is quite ready to replicate that
um there's other people saying you know
this actually could be a good thing if
the world of industry is going to use AI
in this way why shouldn't students get
to grips with it I suppose it's that old
thing that new technology can be used
for good types or bad purposes depending
on its user yeah no that no that's
absolutely true and uh we're all just
rushing to catch up well I am anyway
with what technology is out there and
its implications very briefly
um I fear a story about a lucky student
at a gig fill us in very briefly yeah
yeah so this is a student at a college
in Glasgow who has just got the
opportunity to support Louis Capaldi uh
on tour when he's playing at the the
ovio hydro in Glasgow in front of 12 000
people this is a student who goes to the
new College in Lanark she was asked by
her lecturer if she was free on the 24th
of January I think it was she said yes
and now she's supporting Lewis Capaldi
amazing she said she thought it was a
joke at the time didn't she amazing
stuff yeah we're all out of time see you
again next hour thank you
foreign